("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Tuesday" by JMKM)
I think we need to
have a real hardcore,
real hardcore
YouTube strategy meaning...
Bye guys.
Monday morning.
About to go to a seven hour
off-site with some
of my leadership team.
Work through some
organizational changes.
Strategies, concepts.
Should be a lot of fun.
A lot of work.
Obviously, you guys have
been following the narrative.
All day with the CFO,
all hands on company meeting,
and this full day of off-site.
So, just doing our thing.
Getting alignment with your
direct reports whether that's
one person or 30 is essential.
If your team is not
cohesive you've got no shot.
Pay attention to
March Madness right now.
Look at the subtleties of
the teams that are winning.
It's the cohesiveness of
those five that matter so much.
It's like ballet and
that's how business is.
If you have anything and this is
a great chance to get value out
of my vlog, if right now the
three or four most important
people that work for you are
not aligned with you on vision,
on how much they make,
on where you're going,
if you're not completely,
completely cohesive,
completely step-by-step
like a perfect symphony,
you're vulnerable
and it's up to you,
the leader, to make that work.
And so, you need to face
the things that may be ugly,
your shortcomings,
their shortcomings
when it's your brother.
But communication
amongst the top leadership,
the person and the direct people
that execute that vision
has to be seamless.
Has to, has to.
That's what this day is about.
Hello.
(television static)
("Around The World" by JMKM)
Yeah, mhmmm.
I didn't realize it either
until like a couple days ago.
Looked at my schedule,
I'm like where am I going?
Are you guys, you
have any grasp on your P&amp;L?
Like overhead versus revenue?
No, no, no, no 'cause
that's also that just that's a
theoretical exercise.
I want to know, I want
to know what you want to do.
Care about calling an email,
I care them buying something.
Until they buy something,
we're not done.
we're not done with our mission.
Just 'cause we
mailed them one time,
we got email them again.
We gotta send them
a flyer in the mail.
We gotta call them again.
Get them on the phone.
It's not a small number.
It's a start.
You know what the best part is?
We literally
don't stop until they...
So on Saturday because it's
a weekend and people have
different numbers and
they work differently,
we call everybody.
Every single
person Saturday, Brandon.
Mhmmm.
I actually think those
ten 6-packs should sell.
Especially 'cause you have a
hitters list that should be able
to get it done. You know?
I don't think
hoping is a good strategy.
Well, that's all.
What else the fuck matters?
See ya.
("Around The World" by JMKM)